mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs le
maître de cérémonie de la 40e nuit des
césars de la philosophie
bienvenue à tous à cette 40e cérémonie
des césars de la philosophie
ça fait vraiment plaisir d'être là et
vous vous êtes magnifique avec l'otage
de soirée la plus ça fait un bail qu'on
s'est pas vu et pour ça je vous ai
préparé une cérémonie un petit peu
spéciale dans la catégorie de la
philosophie la plus malsaine
les nommés sont sigmund freud
je me sens vraiment suivi en ce moment
vous devriez couché avec votre mère
sigmund freud docteur j'entends des voix
dans ma tête
vous devriez coucher votre mère et
sigmund freud de l'impression que tout
le monde le regarde
prenez plaisir à faire quelqu'un pardon
est ce que vous aimez lorsque votre anus
se dilate pour laisser passer cette
masse énorme qui est votre cas votre
merde non aboutis bricout chaque vote 9
et le césar est attribué à simon paul
et le césar de la presse qu'on a essayé
de comprendre mais qu'on n'est pas sûr
d'art comprise est attribué à eagle pour
six maps nord devient présente à la
conscience dans son oeuvre l'opposition
du vouloir et de l'accomplir du but et
des moyens le césar du meilleur costume
est attribué à diogène merci le costume
c'est ma maison si césar de l'honnêteté
est remis à socrate moi les gars je sais
que je ne serai césar du meilleur espoir
franck ribéry ne pas trop savoir que je
sache
j'adore ce césar du meilleur cadre e
césar de la meilleure bande originale
césar du philosophe le plus ouvert karl
popper césar du philosophe le plus
visionnaire jean paul sartre césar
d'honneur tu veux du ketchup ou tu fais
de la moutonne dans son ensemble de leur
réalité effective elle même l'unité et
la nécessité de cette opération n'en
sont pas moins également présente
pour le césar de la mort la plus cocasse
les nommés sont sénèque mort dans son
bain epicure mort dans son bain ainsi
encore un peu d'eau chaude
claude françois mort dans son bain pour
le césar de la citation qui est devenu
un piratage de bouffe les nommés sont
carpediem de lucrèce le coeur a ses
raisons que la raison ignore
de pascal ce qui ne tue pas te rend plus
forts de nietzsche enfin un mégot de
genji de tupac ce côté chevauchent sur
l'autre et l'expérience de la
contingence de l'opération est elle-même
seulement une expérience contingentes
eagle merci beaucoup pour ce césar je
voudrais remercier deux ou trois
personnes
elle je voudrais commencer par on
m'entend toujours là vous me voyez je
voudrais remercier ceux qui vont
partager cette vidéo et et mes parents
ce qu'ils vont s'abonner à la chaîne et
mes parents ce qu'ils vont cliquez sur
les zones au vieux monsieur eagle sais
c'est bon je pense qu'on a on a compris
merci à tous ceux qui ont suivi cette
cérémonie nous rendons la tène